una cama improvisada en medio de los
escombros de lo que alguna vez fue un
hogar fotografías de seres queridos en
medio de los restos los que
sobrevivieron al catastrófico terremoto
que azotó a Turquía y Siria están entre
los Afortunados pero ahora alrededor de
dos millones de sobrevivientes turcos
está lidiando con la falta de vivienda y
cientos de miles ya no tienen acceso a
saneamiento básico en ese campamento al
aire libre en antioquía han llegado
baños portátiles pero no lo suficientes
hay restos humanos sobre las aceras
no hay absolutamente ninguna higiene no
morimos en el terremoto Pero estas
enfermedades nos matarán seguro los
trabajadores de la salud están tratando
de ayudar con los problemas mentales y
físicos en esta ciudad de 500.000
habitantes dicen que tratan a más de
1000 personas al día
se están presentando muchas infecciones
de las vías respiratorias superiores
especialmente en niños pequeños si las
condiciones de higiene son malas Por
supuesto que habrá enfermedades
contagiosas pero a pesar de las
solicitudes de medicamentos que ese
riesgo de enfermedades contagiosas no
sea materializado el miedo a las
enfermedades debido a la falta de agua
limpia como el cólera y la sarna se
están extendiendo por los campamentos de
Turquía en Siria la Organización Mundial
de la Salud ha advertido que las
condiciones son aún peores
tenemos que recordar que en Siria hemos
tenido 10 años de guerra el sistema de
salud es increíblemente frágil la gente
ha pasado por un infierno Y esta es la
última atención tanto física como
psicológica para una población que ya
está traumatizada
a medida que los cadáveres continúan
siendo extraídos de los escombros y los
sobrevivientes lidian con el trauma y la
falta de condiciones sanitarias muchos
temen que el próximo capítulo de esta
tragedia sea la enfermedad generalizada